you do is you go through the hard
scho you go
through this hard thing until you can do
it you go through that and in the end
because you're so beaten up physically
mentally you H start humbling yourself
CU you you've done everything you then
when he squeezes it's a gift you go
thanks because I must
actually absorb him I've got to take him
on once you get that then you can start
to expand and
go you can start to but I'm with him all
the
time I can't make you not arrogant and I
can't make you not want to achieve
but once you stop wanting to achieve
you'll be able to do it but only that's
I'm going to save my talking in there
but only if you've got good technique